the most common living arrangement for
men under the age of 30 is still being
at home with their parents yeah and this
is one of the things I I you know I get
a lot of slack on for online because I
talk a lot about age gaps and sometimes
young women you know they go for older
men and they'll say yeah but he's 40 I
know I'm only 22 but at least he'll be
more responsible and he more settled
down but maturity is not defined by age
it's defined by how much responsibility
you have and I always say if he's got to
40 no kids no marriage under his belt
he's chosen that Peter Pan lifestyle no
23-year-old is going to come along and
make him up are you sure you want to be
with them you're better off with a
30-year-old that's got more
responsibility than a 45-year-old who
hasn't because if you think a number
defines maturity you're lost don't be
afraid of being with a man that's had
kids or a man that's you know been
married they're better than the ones
that have had no baggage because baggage
is responsibility which is then
accountability for man